[Music]
[Music]
boom what's up everyone how you doing
welcome to our second ask me anything
I'm your host Don sake on from
simulation and I'm really excited to
talk to you guys about whatever you want
to talk about whatever you want to ask
questions about I wrote in the title
that you could ask me about business ask
me about science ask me about being
asking me about all that is hit me with
your hardest questions hit me with your
most silly and fun questions and we'll
stop provoking questions let's have fun
I'm monitoring the stream on YouTube and
on Facebook so drop your questions into
the stream on YouTube or Facebook we got
some dope backgrounds going on as you
can see here we got the galaxy we also
have the Amazon rainforest as well the
Amazon River it's very nice and tranquil
on the other side we have if we would
like we can pull up our screen and show
you what's going on on the screen or
just the screen by itself and we have
this angle surprise beautiful people
alright I'm ready for those questions
submit them and let's jump right in to
people watching on YouTube
throw me a question I love you guys
thanks for tuning in throw me what you
got to do
[Music]
all right and I'm monitoring on YouTube
as well and Facebook cool all right got
them both up you can have some inception
if you want and check this out what that
looks crazy
all right all right so drop me those
questions I'm pumped so I've been
thinking a lot about a lot of different
things as you know I'm always thinking
about different things always and this
is funny because we're doing this on a
Friday night which I love Bettis is
happening on a sorry Saturday night my
bad
Allen doesn't even know which day the
week it is cuz Allen has his sleep
schedule has been really interesting
lately I've been going to bed at 8 p.m.
and waking up at 4 a.m. it's been super
strange and I've just been editing a lot
of video I've been editing so much video
as you can tell on the channel we've
been having a lot of video uploaded and
it's been very fun to be editing that
much video but at the same time it's a
lot of work to edit that much video all
right I'm gonna share this on my page on
Facebook as well
and like some of our of our Facebook
Ian's to hit us up what up back to the
Amazon reinforce we go all right let's
see what we got
monitoring these streams okay there we
go yo what's up peeps on YouTube thanks
for tuning and I see you guys tuning in
on YouTube we got two peeps watch and
drop me a question I'd love to hear from
you been like I said just thinking a lot
about a lot of different things doing a
lot of video editing we got so many
interviews that have yet to be published
that are just really thought-provoking
and fun and I'm I'm very excited to drop
those but I'm also just backlogged 20 of
them and we a you know FIRST Robotics is
an incredible organization earlier today
I was grateful enough to be able to
emcee the FIRST Tech Challenge
tournament at Google
and it was amazing shout out to Nokomis
the tournament director shout out to
Athena robotics who is this team of of
young ladies 13 18 years old and they're
just super amazingly advocating stem
especially women in stem and it was just
awesome being able to to be there and
and okay okay I see Gabriel joined on
what's up Gabriel thanks for joining on
Facebook hit me with a question my man
would love to would love to hear what
you have to say it dropped me that
question
I love women in stem I love FIRST
Robotics I love inspiring the next
generation of thinkers doers builders
creators and I'm really happy that we
have FIRST Robotics going on should
definitely check out FIRST Robotics if
you haven't yet o KY Faust what's up guy
good to see you my man I saw some of
your stories and Kai's a good good
builder as well also building very
important work into our world
I'm excited Kai dropped me a question my
man I'd love to hear from you Kai's a
good question asker so I'm sure he's
gonna jump in and drop us a question we
still got homies watching on YouTube as
well no questions yet from YouTube let's
see here I'm excited to see what the
first Q is gonna be all that is anything
Brad Smith what's up shout out to Brad
Smith joint on Facebook would love to
hear a question from you drop me a
question we're gonna talk
thought-provoking questions silly
questions let's have fun let's go
anywhere you want business science all
that is being ontology what are the
ontological
well that is a difficult and interesting
question how's that how's that volume
going on in the background yeah that's
good
it's cool music I like that music we can
also play with this yeah what Kenny flow
oh yeah so he can flow one two three
four on the beat let's go who's gonna
drop me that first question I don't know
but I know that I love to ask those
questions and flow when they come at me
I think about him and I shoot him back
at y'all I could go as you can tell I
like to freestyle even though I'm a
straight-up amateur on it but I'll hit
me with the question homies be watching
on Facebook in YouTube and not dropping
me my Q's let's go hit me with those
cues all right okay so I also see there
we go
chi Chi Vaz goes trying to come up with
a question now I love it I love it
that's awesome yeah take your time take
your time finding that question to ask
the homies on YouTube you watch and not
drop and Q's either it's hard it's hard
and putting people on the spot you can
ask a silly question doesn't have to be
something extremely thought-provoking
immediately you know but that is that is
very funny though that it is hard you
get dropped into an AMA and you're like
what should I ask it's fun stuff it's
fun so this is gonna be fun I'm excited
to to answer these questions
the beats are lit I'm glad that we got
those beats going on background alright
we've had enough galaxies back to the
Amazon we go boom man it's such an
incredible thing actually a lot of
people think that the Amazon supplies
most of the world's oxygen but it
actually doesn't and it's not that trees
don't supply most of the world's oxygen
well they actually don't phytoplankton
provide most of the Earth's oxygen if
I'm correct phytoplankton provide about
70 percent of the Earth's oxygen very
tiny beings organisms inside of the
oceans that go through the process of
providing us with oxygen and they're
tiny organisms anyway so that's an
interesting fact there's also just a
tremendous amount of canopy and
organisms that live in the rainforest
behind us and I think it's kind of nuts
that we're divorcing the crap out of it
we got a we have to we have to figure
out how to properly get the resources
that we need for Mother Earth in a
sustainable way and not in an
exploitative greedy corrupt way we are
long long overdue taking better care of
Mother Earth having better stewardship
of Mother Earth I do love her so much
so blessed to be born here it's cool I'm
gonna yeah living this life here on
earth I'm gonna do some more
conversations about the multiverse soon
Oh interesting good question Kai that's
a good place to start us off actually
very good place to start us off all
right
there's make sure there's no okay no
questions on YouTube yet so back
bouncing back to Kai's question alright
Kai Faust on Facebook asks the question
space colonization or focus on earth hmm
all right
that is very interesting want to turn
there we go alright space colonization
our focus on Earth you know when it's
put into a binary it's really difficult
to make an answer so here's a thing
finding the nuance in that question
would be doing both right go forth in a
space but also focus on earth but at the
same time it's like what about where do
we weigh more of our efforts right now
it's extremely important to weigh more
of our efforts on focusing on Earth even
though it's very possible that we can
send those six artists in the rocket
around the moon and that that's amazing
and they will probably come back and do
a lot of beautiful art that will inspire
people to have a better idea of the
overview effect and a better idea of how
to collaborate on this rock it's still
extremely important to really grasp the
full Ness of earth and the fullness of
our focus on this not only on Mother
Earth and the resources and living here
on the planet but also the fact that we
don't understand ourselves that well yet
and I mean whoever tells you that they
know themselves is almost certainly
doesn't actually know themselves because
it takes a lot of self work and I mean
like the most self work you've ever
heard of or done in your life in order
to be able to know yourself it takes a
lot of mindfulness a lot of meditation a
lot of psychedelics a lot of inward
practices a lot of inward practices and
so if we don't know ourselves and we
don't know how to have ethics around
civilizational dynamics and we don't
know how to maximize the potential of
all beings on this planet and not just
the ones that are able to pass their
time on maximizing their life outcomes
because right now a tremendous amount of
people are living in situations that
don't maximize their life outcomes that
don't unleash the full creative
potential of their soul
that's where the focus on earth should
be on figuring out the resources the
frameworks and how to enable people to
maximize to the fullest potential we got
to get to that focus on earth for us to
be able to more easily go through space
this is similar Oh interesting
Kai Foss drops another question it's
good time for this transition I'm down
with it all right so we got on YouTube
we got three people watching and on
YouTube go ahead and drop a question on
YouTube come on homies drop that
question in the chat and I'll reply on
YouTube all right back to Facebook Kai
faust asks the question do you think
andrew yang has it right it's a time for
you bi so we did a show with Andrew yang
a couple months ago he's a Democratic
presidential candidate for 2020 running
on the platform of universal basic
income freedom dividend is what he calls
it and he wants to allocate $1,000 per
month per person in the United States
and universal basic income is extremely
interesting and there's there definitely
some sort of nuance that is it's you
know just just yesterday we were talking
to Tony Lane casually who was teaching
us about universal Earned Income a
universal earned incomes a little bit
different in the sense that it gives
people something of value to do so it
brings civilization some sort of value
and it brings them some sort of meaning
in life that they do that thing and then
they earn the money which I thought was
kind of interesting because in that
sense it's earned income and earned
income seems to affect the soul
differently than just given income I
mean we can all refer to this ourselves
where we think about well what happens
when someone just gives you a thousand
dollars versus when you actually have to
do something for that thousand dollars
maybe you would like work for five hours
and you provide them with something and
they just really liked it and then gave
you a thousand bucks for it without you
expecting anything in return so when
things like that happened I think that's
actually quite did
friend so it's actually more about
meaning and more about fulfillment than
anything else but it's also of course
about just the sheer amount of resource
flows that are going on on the planet
because the resource flows are a little
bit back like we were talking about
earlier and those wack resource flows
are causing a lot of unnecessary
suffering and it's not enabling people
to as easily actualize into our world
and so that's why Kai that ubi is it's
going in the right direction there's
something about there being an unlimited
amount of resources on this planet Earth
having everything that we absolutely
need in order to thrive but we just
don't know how to properly allocate and
distribute the resources to maximize the
thriving of everybody does that
necessarily mean the thousand bucks a
month as a freedom dividend I'm not
exactly sure does it mean figuring out
how to just just literally change some
of the resource flows provide providing
people with the ability to maximize
their full potential unleash their soul
fully absolutely what is that not sure
but I'm extremely interested in that
because that's gonna lead to the
greatest economic prosperity on the
planet when every single person is able
to creatively endeavor and execute what
they care about into the world and it
does that sometimes
really you know I I don't you could
could you possibly say in a binary way
that if that if people were given a
thousand bucks a month that for some
reason that zero percent of people would
choose to not do anything but order food
via drones and watch television shows
because I think that people would do
that I don't know how many people one
percent three percent ten percent but to
say it's zero percent is wrong so so
that that automatically makes it so that
Kai Faust
all right let's tie Faust came in with
another question let's go check on on
the youtubes as well okay YouTube still
got three watching No
chats YouTube hit us up with the chat on
the YouTube alright back to the Facebook
Kai Faust drops another question
Caiaphas been coming in the clutch with
the questions much love much love
alright he says you've probably answered
this somewhere but do we live in a
simulation interesting so I actually
only started unpacking this a little bit
in one of the recent videos thoughts on
reality that I actually didn't get a
chance to fully finish but the it's a
good question and all of your questions
have been lit Khai good work
here's the thing about simulation theory
what we live in we don't understand
there you go
that starts us off if you think you
understand what you live in then you're
to hubristic you're too overly
self-confident in your faculties of
perception and you just can't be
there's too much nuance there's too much
multi variability there's too many
factors that are going into reality into
what's going on how can you possibly
understand every single dynamic of
civilization both in the
three-dimensional reality and I mean
everything from governments and politics
and economics and educational systems
and the way that the brain forms of
every single mind into the world and the
way that water food and resources are
distributed around the planet I mean how
can you know every single nuance of that
and that's only the 3d how language has
evolved how evolution has it just in
general evolved and that's 3d and then
you go outside of the 3d and we're
talking about things like okay when you
have a very spiritual experience when
you are connecting to the infinite when
you are connecting to that infinite
whether it's called God or consciousness
or all that is or whatever you want to
call it infinity that when you are
communing with that force whatever that
force is through meditation prayer
psychedelics lots of mindfulness
practice whatever it may be that that is
so ethereal and there's something so far
beyond the 3d that we don't understand
so then there's that on top of it so
when you're crunching all these
variables it just changes your
understanding that you know nothing okay
then if you know nothing then what did
everything start from who are we where
are we what are we doing here
are all these questions meaningless like
okay how do I know how did we get here
okay Big Bang okay well what happened
before the Big Bang well we don't know
okay well what but why are we here we
don't know why we're here well maybe
we're here for a greater purpose maybe
we're supposed to survive in this galaxy
in the solar system maybe we were
supposed to thrive as a planet in the
world it's extremely difficult to answer
this question about simulation theory
but one of the most important things
about simulation theory that you can
embody is the realization that we live
in an extremely complex
three-dimensional reality so we know
nothing and then we don't know anything
about what exists outside of the
three-dimensional reality whether or not
there are actually forces at play on the
planet that are beyond our perception
and that those things together make it
so that you just can't answer that
question binary just people that are
answering that question binary are
missing the nuance same thing with you
bi same thing with space college they
should focus on Earth these questions
have been great it's just extremely
important to fully embody the nuance
another thought that about simulation
theory that's really important is that I
think a lot about you know multiverse is
a lot about what's going on and I'll do
a video on this in a little more in
depth but I don't there are so many
Allen's that I just feel all these
different Allen's that are breaking out
and running into different realities
right now
and I also feel that same way when I
empathize with someone very deeply like
excuse me like earlier today one of our
friends was talking about falling and
hurting themselves and the more that I
get behind their eyes the more that I
get behind their body who they are and
what they care about and their
experience that they had the more that I
realized that I am them and they are me
and that it's very strange it's a very
strange line to to to like to border on
and to and to conversate on because a
lot of people don't necessarily get that
I am someone else and they are also me
and it's a difficult conversation to
have so good stuff good stuff I can take
that so many more ways and what up what
up youtubers for people on YouTube
what's up drop a drop a comment in the
in the chat would love to would love to
hear from you also on Facebook thank sky
appreciate your comments on empathy and
oneness thank you thank you Kai yeah I
know nothing Kai and I appreciate your
questions because they're they're really
strong questions and difficult to know
you know to have answers to I really I
appreciate that a lot
and please critique me as well I'd love
to hear critiques as well please hit me
with some critiques like what can I do
better
good question Kai Fox coming in and with
another power question do you want to
live forever these are good questions
why man these are good questions living
forever one could ask you know what
happens on the void before you're born
and after you're dead what goes on on
those two Sparks before and after those
Sparks and life is in between your this
life is in between well
hmm
because if it's possible that we do also
live on the before spark and the after
spark that we live on those other sides
then we potentially already live forever
and it's interesting to think about that
and it also has a it has an it there's
there's a there's an implication to
living forever that's a little bit
strange because there's this beautiful
essence to being a seven year old and a
14 year old and these youthful years in
the essence of those youthful years is
if we can just retain that essence
throughout our life the seven or
fourteen year old body and mind and soul
and just keep living in the 3d that
could be very interesting at the same
time you know just going back to the you
know to the living forever and
simulation just when you're you know
when you're done you know you just snap
out of just envisioning worlds planets
orbiting other stars that have their own
worlds evolved around them or just
digitally going from atoms to bits so
you're actually going in programming the
design of the world that you want to
live in and when you program the design
of the world you want to live in you can
just hop eighty years I lived through
this world here on earth and boom I'm
into the next world whatever I designed
wherever I want to go next and I enter
in and I just forget that I came from
that in-between stage and now I'm in
this next world where I'm playing for
ten years 50 years a hundred years
however long I want to set to play for
and I'm going through some sort of a
challenge that this that this is
something that I'm being challenged to
go through on this planet like I
frequently think that I'm challenged my
challenge on this mission this is a
mission this mission to come to earth
orbiting this star with this specific
civilization that has evolved
and it's my mission to figure out how to
help humanity understand the roots of
where they came from and how to maximize
flourishing living together to get them
to the next rocks and to help them just
maximize their own potential that that
is this mission for me and that the next
mission will be exciting and different
than this mission and I just want to I
want to level up I want to have fun
I want to help people that that is my
mission this this mission this life on
this planet so that loops us all the way
back to you know the living forever Plus
simulation comment that might have been
one of my favorite ways that I've ever
replied to that and I hope it resonates
with people because that's a that's
that's a it's a tough one to explain
let's see what's going on on the
youtubes all right youtubes we're up to
eight viewers all right yo youtubers
we're up to eight of you hook us up with
the question from the youtubes all of
the questions have come from the
Facebook and from Kai Faust shout out
let's get let's get it let's get a
question from you from the youtubes
throw it up in the chat I'll answer it
remember funny silly super
thought-provoking you know you pick
let's play nice guy you said great
response I appreciate that my man I do I
do seriously treat this experience as
just so blessed to have this experience
of of this mission on the planet does
anyone else just feel like sometimes
it's you're trying to get behind the
eyes of other people and as you like try
to get behind the eyes of those other
people that you like struggle a little
bit because there just seems to be some
sort of a dark force that's commanding
them like who they
are and what they feel and it's almost
like you're not even talking to them but
you're talking to a dark force that's in
control of them and I guess a way to
explain this would be like you know when
you when you just talk to someone that
is just so like like a such a lover of
violence or a lover of oppression or a
lover of materialism or conspicuous
consumption or all these different
things you know you're talking someone
that's like a lover of those things in
one regard or another and you just try
your best to like to sync up with them
on a way that you understand them and
you ask them questions to try and learn
from them and who they are and how they
got there and you know they just speak
to you in such a way that is so distant
from any sort of spiritual communion
with all that is they speak like on the
exact opposite side of that where they
where it almost seems like that their
essence has no interest in working
together with other humans to prosper
and and if that's the case then you have
such a severe disconnect from the other
and I actually have am seeing that you
know I actually really like spending
time alone because I find it very
difficult to find other people like that
that are the opposite of that person
that are trying to commune with the
infinite and try and manifest some sort
of a gorgeous actualization
of civilization as a pinnacle species in
the cosmos Caiphas I'm inclined to feel
like free will does not exist when I
empathize with others interesting that's
so interesting
Anton what's up brother Anton Bart's
self joined what's up brother on
Facebook nice to hear from you man I'll
be interviewing Patrick bet David in
Dallas in a week and we should hang out
when I'm there I'll DM you about that
later on the youtubes all right no still
no comments on the YouTube eight people
watching on the YouTube but no comments
hook us up youtubers goes up with that
comment
I'd love to hear a question from you
guys Anton hit me with your question -
I'd like to hear from you Kai you know
six people watching on Facebook
shout-out to all you guys much love I'm
Kai Kai your last comment was very
interesting this comment that I'm
inclined to feel like free will does not
exist when I empathize with others hmm
as though the more deeply that we
empathize with people that potentially
have maybe maybe less of a communion
with the infinite a less of a spiritual
connection with all that is and with
humanity and trying to prosper that Kai
and I potentially feel like free will
does not exist so much that there is
some sort of a force that is in command
of that entity of that human that is not
enabling them to fully be and so I agree
with that if I'm on point with what you
said Kai then you know let me know cuz I
I do feel I do feel somewhat that way
shout out to the you know you guys
always know I'm always rockin who will
teach robots ethics mug it's a great
question you know who's gonna teach
humans ethics as well how do we do that
Kai Foss exactly Andrew what's up Andrew
Cornfeld how you doin man shout out to
Andrew much love much love thank you for
tuning in greatly appreciate it give me
a give me a comment ants on Andrew give
me common guys nice alright cool
aunt sounds thinking of a question says
such a dope set up bro looks awesome
much love appreciate that my man thank
you
you'll see it when you come to SF
YouTube YouTube hook it up it's funny
that people watch on YouTube but they're
talking a little bit less that's
interesting that on Facebook people are
talking more than they are on YouTube
yeah seven watching on YouTube but no
comments yet very interesting very very
interesting all right on to the let's
see what we got for music Wow
Anton's thinking of this question I want
to mess with this let's play with this
[Music]
all right
all right bring that down boom all right
we have new questions from Andrew and
Anton all right what does living forever
say about our identity from Andrew
interesting and we'll get to Anton's
question what's the point of fun
interesting in a moment so these are
interesting questions good job guys
these are good so good I like it what
does living forever say about our
identity mm-hmm well let me see if I can
angle this in direction that makes sense
well if if we do live forever let's say
let's say that we there's something
outside of the eighty years when the
void pre-birth so there's a void
pre-birth and there's a void post-death
that if on those two ends that something
else happens out there and that we do
potentially live forever
what does that say about our identity
well it may just say that the life that
we live in right now in this life this
mission that we're living on this rock
at this time this 80 year period that
this is only a small part of our
identity that our identity is
potentially so much more interesting
like okay we got another comment from
Andrew like identity seems to be
organization not matter interesting yeah
yeah yeah yeah this is good stuff mm-hmm
yeah identity seems to be organization
not matter yeah yeah I don't know enough
about what happens in uh in the void
pre-birth and post death there have been
a good amount of people that have
that have been talking to us about that
and it's really interesting when I get
to talk to them about it and I would
love to hear your thoughts more Eric
Matzner yo shout-out to new troe shout
out to the to the nootropics much love
man much love good to change cameras
much love much love to Eric master
thanks for tuning in my man all right
let me see if I can power through some
of these questions Anthony bar two
sauces what's the point of fun um the
point of fun that's a really good
question I think I think if you do what
you love every single moment of your
life than every single moment of your
life is fun but you have to do what you
love every single moment of your life
it's it's hard to explain every moment
of the journey no matter where the
vicissitude is the up or the down has to
be confine has to be an amazing movie
every second of the movie of your life
and then the fun is the play is the work
it's all one together you know so I
guess that would be my my comment about
that and let's see do that Eric says hai
cái' do the needs of the many outweigh
the needs of the few hmm oh nice Anton
Bart self says nailed it brother that's
good too the comment about fun I'm glad
you like that my man I'm glad you like
that thanks for thanks for saying that
keep uh you know keep on keep on helping
me improve these answers let me know
what you think I can do better okay cut
do the needs of the many outweigh the
needs of the few your questions have
been great guys keep them coming needs
of the many outweigh the needs of the
few huh well would the needs of the many
be the fact that all seven point seven
billion of us need water and food and
shelter and air and the basic needs of
life
education healthcare electricity that
kind of stuff is that what the needs of
the many mean I would like every single
person to have those basic necessities
and I would and I don't know how to
maximally provide them to everyone yet
and I think we all do we just don't know
how to maximally provide every single
bit to people that they need in order to
maximally flourish basically just in
short quick there is a thirst there are
structural violence --is in the
hierarchy that prevent people from
advancing up the hierarchy those
structural hierarchies those oppressions
those greed and corruptions that are
holding people back from their fullest
from their self-actualization that those
things specifically are what needs to be
expelled from the hierarchy as soon as
possible and what that does is it
enables people to more easily self
actualize so that's that would be maybe
my answer to the many versus the few and
I'd like maybe to clarify more with you
in the future on that to understand it
better nine people on face book what's
up fam thanks for watching everyone on
Facebook you'll hit us with the question
nine out of nine people hit us with the
question over there uh on the YouTube
interesting nine people also watching on
the YouTube and no hope there we go
melody good and my phone and the message
is retracted melody good and sent a
comment on YouTube our first comment and
the message got retracted it said like
my phone something maybe it was like my
phone's not letting me or something but
I don't know oh there we go
our our Lee our our Lee says hi on
YouTube what's up our Lee good to hear
from you thanks for commenting
appreciate it
yeah even just a comment saying hi on
YouTube it's great to see some chat
going on there alright throw us a
question on the YouTube or on the
Facebook anything you want anything you
want peeps Oh interesting Chi says for
future discussion the
a problem um just just to quickly
address the trolley problem keep up the
good work or I'll count you go there we
go I think I think that might be Ron
commenting with the simulation account
and he might have I don't know if he's
purposely commenting with a simulation
account or the or he was trying to do
his personal count I don't know why is
there air oh that's a good question all
right hold on back to Kai's question for
a future discussion to Charlie problem
just a quick bit a quick bit on the
trolley problem that you guys might find
interesting
think about it this way and this is just
this is just a challenging point some
people aren't gonna like this but I
typically like things that other people
don't like okay put someone like Elon
Musk that is building Tesla and SpaceX
and these important organizations for
the sustainable progress of humanity
let's let's just say that or even
someone even throw Gandhi into the
equation let's say that lets say that
Gandhi's in on the trolley problem okay
so let's say that a spiritual leader or
a technology leader one of the two or
both or whatever you want to say is on
one of the train tracks for the trolley
problem and for those that don't know
the trolley problem is how does one make
a decision to hit one person or hit
three people and if they have to make
the decision if they're just for some
reason they have to make the decision
and for this I always ask how do you
gauge the value of a human it's
extremely difficult to understand but if
someone is leading spiritually leading a
billion people on the planet to
self-actualization and the other three
people are just are maybe they are just
consuming things from drones that are
shipping them food and watching
television is it really a question to
pick the three people that are using
drones to ship them food and and do all
doing that all day and
and watching television versus the
spiritual leader that's leading a
billion people to self-actualization I
don't think that's a question because I
think there's a clear answer to that
it's extremely weird because there's
three lives versus one life but one of
them is making so much more impact so
you have to measure impact and it's
difficult to measure impact in that
trolley in that trolley question um and
then there's another aspect of the
trolley question which I think every
single person every single person should
answer this question about themselves
and that that question about themselves
is would you if you had to for some
reason would you kill yourself for the
other 7 point 7 billion people to
survive let's just say you were given
for some reason that option that you had
to ultimatum you had to kill yourself or
distress the society to live seven and a
half seven point seven billion people
the insane thing is is that we a lot of
us think like of course I'd kill myself
to make sure society lives on seven and
seven point seven billion or everyone
dies is the other option and society
dies right there and so I I think it's
it seems to be very clear for a lot of
people and then it'd be hard to pull the
trigger but we would have to pull the
trigger and then for a bunch of people I
don't think for a bunch of people would
say yes to that anyway that's for one
thing why is there air good question
Blake Blake what's up my man Blake tuned
in Blake are you large tuned in what's
up man thanks for tuning in I just want
to check the YouTube oh my gosh we got
comments on YouTube okay Josh Morin
commented on YouTube thoughts on spiral
dynamics Wow I don't know what spiral
dynamics are and for that we will
transfer to the YouTube alright spiral
dynamics and I mean by the YouTube
dynamics I meant I meant the Google
search so alright let's also change this
to mixed effects three so you can see me
at the same time so spiral dynamics a
way of understanding human nature is a
psychological approach that offers
insights into people's worldviews and
how the
shape values and drive behavior oh my
gosh this is really when you know
nothing Don like when I know nothing Don
Edward Beck right here oh sorry I should
zoom in for you guys
so spiral dynamics a psychological
approach that offers insights into
people's worldviews and how these shape
values and drive behavior okay that
sounds really interesting
Don Oder Beck is a teacher geopolitical
advisor and theorist focusing on
applications of large scale psychology
including social psychology evolutionary
psychology organizational psychology in
effect on human socio cultural systems
co-author of spiral dynamics theory
interesting I guess we'll go to Donna to
Rebekah sees the co-author of the theory
and shout out shout out to Josh more in
here I'm gonna write here and it
couldn't do it I can zoom in for some
reason but shout out to Josh Marin
alright let's look back that's a good
question an evolutionary human this is
spiral dynamics human development model
spent many years adapting the work of
his mentor and colleague Devon to a
psychologist Claire W Graves professor
emeritus in Psych interesting well
development of the theory publishes
theory of human development a
biopsychosocial systems framework of
value systems as applied to human
socio-cultural evolution which posits
that the psychology of the mature human
being transitions from a current level
of cultural existence based on current
life conditions to a more complex level
in response to or to cope with changes
in existential reality wow this is
fascinating holy cow interesting so so
whoa mmm all right so this is called
spiral dynamics and from my first
thoughts on it in in it's a framework of
value system so it's in in essence it's
the mature ation of the hue
being transitioned so as in as in I as a
human and birthed into the world with a
very not evolved mental model of reality
and over time my mental model grows and
some people's mental model grows
exponentially greater than other people
because they're able to just parse
reality for the most signal possible
about the truth of what's actually going
on in all of the cybernetics of all the
systems and how they work together and
and it seems as though here that what
Don Beck was talking about was that
engraves had published his theory is
that that we as we evolved we mature and
we move from a point of of Arc just
these current life conditions to a more
complex level in response to the changes
in existential reality model
demonstrates the dual nature interesting
this is interesting I know nothing about
this I'm trying to learn more about it
let's go back to miss effects three
[Music]
model demonstrates the dual nature of
human social emergence with state
changes between communal / collective
value systems both sacrificing self and
individualistic expressing self value
systems interesting oh that's so
interesting so maybe then maybe then and
I again I just have to read about this
more but that there's this interesting
balance between the amount of
individualism that one should have in
terms of just them being able to survive
in the world get themselves food water
shelter etc but also to sacrifice
themselves for the greater good of
humanity prospering and so that's very
very interesting I need to learn more
about this and shout out shout out that
that went on for a while spiral dynamics
other comments from YouTube were I'll
get to Facebook in a second melody
Gooden why things have to be so
spiritual that's funny
and and you know I think I think
everything is
spiritual it's spirit doesn't need to
mean something that has negative
connotation and different people have
different perspectives of what of what
that is but you know all that is has all
these different Sciences and spirits
spiritualities and everything baked into
it all right in
Oh David what's up what's up my man
David mija Dion tuned in it's good to
hear from you my man David's a a
childhood friend of mine so is his
brother Robert and their family we're
just good friends from from Sioux Falls
South Dakota I'll actually be in Sioux
Falls hosting a live event for anyone
that's tuning in from Sioux Falls let's
go to my hometown will be hosting a live
event in Sioux Falls at the Bell bus
theatre on December 30th which is a
Sunday it's a matinee show from 2:00 to
4:00 p.m. I will be doing a talk
followed by an interview that guest that
has yet to be named and that's gonna be
really exciting David's question is what
do you think of the Ship of Theseus
thesis thought experiment okay another
another thing that people are back we go
to the good old search Google all right
in the metaphysics of identity the ship
of the see us or theseus's paradox is a
thought experiment that raises the
question of whether a ship standing for
an object in general that has all had
all of its components replaced remains
fundamentally the same object oh wait
what these questions are so interesting
what okay so if you if you replace if
you replace every single component of a
ship is it the same ship is it the same
object interesting
and that's a paradox yeah hmm it's
interesting thought experiment I don't
know I do love I love it when I just I
don't know that's a good one that's a
good one and I think something
interesting about it at least at least
something I can say is interesting about
it is that when you think about it are
you are you replacing the actual the
actual atoms and the actual particles
and the actual you know planks are you
going that deep are you replacing every
single tiny substrate possible from that
and replacing it with the the exact same
substrate but it is it a different
substrate or is it the same one you know
there's that and then there's also
another thought that I just had about it
was that it's kind of interesting that
just you know looking at it here just
thinking about it for if it truly is a
if it is just a calculation if it's just
a you know if it's just a variable that
you're adjusting that the parts are
changing on the ship anyway this is very
interesting very complex I like I like I
would love to hear what your thoughts
are every guy's why don't go and write
this in the comments write your thoughts
in the comments we'd love to hear from
you you know go and write what your
thoughts are to the answers to these
questions in the comments below
all these questions throughout the show
just start writing your answers to them
and then we'll feature them on our
Instagram and on our stories and on our
Twitter and we'll go back and we'll do
more of these a mas and we'll feature
your answer so go and answer these
questions with your thoughts because
they're very interesting and I'm sure
that you all have powerful powerful
answers all right
quick back to YouTube Khan Bay Han
what's the correlation between spectrum
of happiness sadness and the visible
light part of the electromagnetic
spectrum wow that's a good question
quick let me that's a really good
question let's go back to Facebook quick
Facebook damn Facebook got a lot of
comments Rhys Jones joined shout out to
Rhys Jones damn there's a lot of
comments on Facebook now shout out to
Rhys Jones shot
to VIN win as well to shout-out to you
guys okay
damn alright let me get let me get that
answer on youtube and then I'll jump
over to Facebook for a moment and then
we'll come back to YouTube alright and
what's the correlation between spectrum
of happiness sadness and the visible
light part of the electromagnetic
spectrum interesting con okay I think I
finally wrap my mind around your
question it's a good question so con bae
han shoutout to you let's imagine
happiness and sadness are on a spectrum
let's say happiness is over here and
sadness is over here and then could
potentially higher vibration potentially
the the the higher faster frequencies on
the electromagnetic spectrum be closer
to happiness and could sadness be slower
wavelength frequencies is that possible
I actually think there is potentially
some sort of of of an understanding of
that that is that is that is somewhat
true is that if you have the most
profound sort of communion with the
infinite that you do feel like it's just
SuperDuper deeply profoundly like just
shooting up it's just you know the turd
the Taurus in the Kundalini the you know
you're got the energy flow coming from
your head and going out your spine and
your lower back it's coming back in and
just that that feeling feels very high
vibe and then sadness I actually cool I
just want to say sadness for some reason
also has something for me to do with how
addicted we are to sex and sugar and
drugs and those things just the
pleasure-seeking and we just had Rob
Lustig on the show go look at our recent
show of dr. Rob Lustig because he calls
out sugar calls out process who calls
out drugs calls out and these things are
pleasure short term short term short
term and I think that was what leads to
sadness at least the depression at least
anxiety is the short term gratification
seeking habits of pleasure instead of
long term happiness content inist
of and prosperity and
peace and kindness so anyway I think
that's a very interesting question I
don't know the answer to that konban
that's good okay let's jump over to
Facebook quick back over to Facebook we
go let's answer some of your questions
on Facebook much love everyone for these
great questions okay why is there air
I'm pretty sure this came from Ron
Vargas because he's commenting the
producer director the show he's
commenting from simulation why is there
air okay it's a great question hmm
okay so how did this evolve to have
oxygen why why did oxygen evolve as one
of the elements of the periodic table as
one of these abundant elements of the
periodic table like carbon and why do we
breathe that oxygen for life and why do
plants you know
expel oxygen for us to breathe and
whatnot why why do other mammals also
you know breathe in this oxygen and
stuff that's an interesting question
you know what you can think about is why
is there Oh air not even just oxygen
interesting I I missed
I'm SMS I went straight to oxygen
because air there's also air is a
majority nitrogen I think it's like 60
plus percent nitrogen and then and then
only about 22% yeah
oxygen yeah yeah yeah and like 60 or
almost 70% nitrogen anyway um and so you
know the different there's different
compositions of air on different rocks
orbiting stars so Mars has a different
composition of air and then if you look
even like further to for example you
take a another rock that's orbiting a
star and you analyze the air composition
on that rock orbiting the star then it's
gonna be a different composition Ron is
calling right now on Facebook
I answered let's see let's see how this
let's see how this works out
hi Ron you're calling in right now
ron's having a good time watching I love
you Ron thank you and I'll talk to you
soon
keep up the good work much love that I'm
glad that he called in that was that was
great it's a good question though
because again the air composition
changes on different rocks orbiting
stars okay
Andrews next question sorry about that
alright Andrews question at Vision
weekend I had a guy who wants to live
forever say to me as I pressed him on
his desires look man we know there is
probably just a whole lot of nothing
after death bring the supplements a new
man I can zoom in on it awesome
all right a vision weekend I had a guy
in shout-out to foresight Institute we
we appreciate foresight Institute a lot
a Bay Area organization out here that's
really pushing forth the ball on thought
provoking conversations about the future
of humanity a vision we can I had a guy
who wants to live forever say to me as I
press them on his desires look man we
know there is probably just a whole lot
of nothing after death I don't want a
whole lot of nothing Wow
I replied you are made of 99.9% nothing
[Music]
so our solar systems you know solar
systems made up of 99% nothing atoms
made up of 99% nothing it cetera it's
just interesting what even is something
and is it really different than nothing
it's a very very interesting question
what even is something is it really
different than nothing well
um first of all what is that guy doing
saying look man we know there is
probably just a whole lot of nothing
after death I don't want a whole lot of
nothing it's like dude you don't have
answers that's we know there is probably
just a whole lot of nothing after death
like well I don't want a whole lot of
nothing anyway it's like find the nuance
anyway whatever and then what even is
something and is it really different
than nothing
yeah I guess are something and nothing
two sides of the same coin do you call
Earth orbiting the star something do you
call Earth something and Sun something
and the space between the two nothing do
you call the electron something and the
neutron and protons something and the
space between them nothing it's strange
I guess they are something and then the
space between them is nothing mmm or is
it all something is everything something
or is everything nothing that's a very
interesting question don't have the
answer
bro your streaming setup is so gangster
much love Anton thank you oh my goodness
look at those cam angles shout out shout
out to these cam angles what hold on let
me get let me get you let me get you
guys a little bit of love on on that on
this on this cam so you can see how the
other robos work you can get some love
on the on the robotics what uh so that's
some robotic gangsta action and yeah you
got it you got to have you got to be
able to you know mess around with try
casters is extremely important stuff
Blake asks what do you think of radical
acceptance wow what a good question man
we're getting to the good questions damn
a lot of people are tuning in now our
numbers are increasing and the questions
are increasing very quickly I got to
spend less time on questions so we can
get to more of them
this is a good one radical acceptance
what do you believe is the solution to
being all accepting let's get that um
let's get you guys on that split screen
so you can check it out all right Blake
what do you think of radical acceptance
what do you believe is the solution to
being all accepting oh that's so
interesting so interesting well let's
start with that so feels like we've been
applying human rights rather than
getting to sources of the issue yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay Blake yeah you're
going in the right direction here I'm
glad you're pulling this up so I think
what's I think what's what's happening
is a deep disconnect shout out to
bernard gunther here there's a
profoundly deep disconnect from our own
ability to understand ourselves like who
am i who am i who what is this and who
are you and what are you and what is
your fullest potential your fullest
creative potential on this planet
because if we get that about you if you
understand that about yourself and i
understand that about myself that makes
our relationship much easier like we
don't have to fight each other for
things that you get you i get me and
that we get how to cooperate and live
amongst each other on this rock so i
would say that that is a part of this
radical acceptance is that if it's again
it's this root of the issue the solution
to being all accepting is to understand
oneself like understanding oneself and
having you understand yourselves and
having us all understand who we are and
how we can be our best in the world and
then working together that I think will
eradicate the greed eradicate the
corruption eradicate the malevolence
that goes on the structural violence is
and it'll enable us all to prosper more
easily also just the true reality as
technologies like decentralization will
help us get there much faster the
centralization that goes on in this
planet is really freakin bad that it
just there's too many people that have
too much
power that can manipulate too many
variables because their power
centralized when power becomes
decentralized and we incentivize good
behavior across these different nodes
that decentralize power that is a
fantastic way to maximize prosperity I'm
a huge fan of decentralization and we
got to figure that out as fast as
possible in all of its regards I like
that question about radical acceptance
let's get there as soon as possible
all right um is it ethical to eat
animals interesting question kai um I'll
just jump directly to it I'm really
excited for the clean meat revolution
that's happening this means actually
just taking stem cells from chickens and
pigs and cows and the animals that we
like to eat and just growing the the
cells out in massive bio reactors and
then inducing them as fat or as muscle
and then just making that into meat in
just ubiquitous quantities for the
entire world to eat after desire that's
frickin awesome I'm really excited for
that but continuing radical acceptance
here let's go back to let's have you
guys shake sell but continue radical
acceptance seems to end up paradoxically
creating a flourishing environment for
evil to flourish yes Blake that is super
lit that's well set very very well set
the more that we say oh everyone just
love each other just you know just love
each other if you just love one another
that's the answer it is love is the
answer but the problem is that if we
love each other to the extent of loving
each other so much that we just think
that oh all the evil is just gonna go
away if we love each other
it doesn't quite go away like that
there's geopolitical and economic
pressures that are pushing the
negativity the malevolence and the greed
and the corruption into the love so even
if we love each other there are still
corruption eating into the loving
systems so it requires a very severe how
do you how do you get all seven point
seven billion people to love so that
there is no malevolence well I'm
starting to think there's only two
options
there's the top-down which is if you
would go and try and get everyone at the
United Nations to meditate and practice
mindfulness and maybe
up on psychedelics with each other
that's a top down the bottom-up approach
is I think easier which is the
grassroots movements of spiritual people
around the world to just really really
hyper work on themselves first and
figure out themselves and how to love
themselves and love each other and then
spread that to more and more grassroots
entities and people and just keep
building it across the world and then
that will then spread around and get us
to I think where we need to go oh wow oh
nice David just heads up David and
Andrew we're asking about the same thing
with ship of theseus that's so
interesting it's about the relationships
of the atoms not the atoms themselves
interesting good point is that here let
me bring that up for you guys to see
that yeah there is something interesting
about the relationship of as in as in
literally if nobody is watching Earth
this earth even exists there's a lot of
the observer effect that we don't
understand the Hawthorne effect is very
interesting we did a video on that you
guys can watch that on our Channel
yeah and there's a lot more about the
ship of thesis that I don't understand
in the relationships of of observation
all right I'm gonna migrate off of the
Facebook to the YouTube to see what's
been going on on the YouTube alright on
the YouTube we have we have our cells
get replaced every 7 to 10 years yet
we're the same object okay well well you
may look like you you as a physical
object from the exterior are the same
but every single second your heart is
beating and you know you're one sec when
your one heartbeat closer to death and
so if your hearts beating every single
second and your
inching closer and closer to death all
the biochemical reactions are going
inside you you're the process of aging
is occurring you are aging
second-by-second is that really the same
entity no it's like when you look at a
river and then you wait a minute and you
look at the river again you're not
seeing the same h2o molecules you're not
seeing this
water that water is way downstream now
you're looking at different water same
thing with this light that's coming and
hitting my face right the photons come
the photons come they come every every
millisecond these photons keep coming
and coming right and so it's a different
but that's interesting could you please
start over and state who you are and
what you do Oh melody good and says I
totally don't know this guy me either
not in description well actually it
technically technically it is
interesting that you found this and that
you and that you don't know who it is so
I guess that's a good point is that I
should write it at the very top of the
description sure there are also lots of
people that tune in and know I guess who
I am but lower in the bio of the video
just a heads up to you guys lower in the
bio of the video it does say watch
allen's TEDx talk and follow Alan
Instagram and Twitter and I did I did at
the beginning actually say that you know
I'm Alan the host of simulation and you
guys can watch any of our previous
long-form nuance driven interview
content on our Channel all right Ron
says hi Alan
[Music]
I want melody good and says I want to
give me a shot because I seem lost yeah
yeah sure sure give me give me the you
know give me the good kids bad give me
whatever you got assume he's trying to
be science but use theoretical
physicists and me too who are you sorry
asking for my 10 this is very very
strange there's a lot of strange
comments that are going on on the
YouTube side of things how this is my
actual name okay what's up man yeah I
kind of used to do you said 10 ounce
piano fight shows nice nice man yeah we
used to do shows that piano fight for
those that don't know we used to do
science comedy shows at piano fight and
that's where a lot of our interest for
science communication definitely started
okay I'm gonna switch back to Facebook
okay this guy's philosophical so know
who he has need to know who he is and
what his job is he's for hallucinogens
at the U and haha these YouTube comments
are so lit there's so funny
check these out check these out look at
this so we get this over here I don't
know oh I can zoom in okay look at this
he's for hallucinogens at the UN that's
so funny that you can just get labeled
like that don't dis persons for that
thing it's like nah there was a lot more
nuance to it than just hallucinogens
what the UN it's like now there's
there's there's there's good ways to to
be able to explore something like that
in its nuance and slowness and
gentleness and kindness with the proper
way of executing it okay so yo melody
Gooden I you know I I really appreciate
you saying that you know you don't know
who I am and that you would you know
like to know who I am and what my job is
I host a show called simulation which
you are literally watching right now you
can go subscribe to the channel go watch
these videos but the show simulation
features some of the greatest minds of
our time what we do is we have long-form
nuanced multidisciplinary conversation
with these leaders and we have multi
camera shoot here in our recording
studio in San Francisco and there's 250
of these interviews on our channel over
just the last year you can go watch
these nuance conversations we also do
very short videos 3060 1 minute 30 60
second or 1 minute videos and
shorter videos are either clips from
those interviews or they're just really
nice videos that we produce with our
friends and one of them is Paul let's
shout out to Paul let one of the best
artists we know anyway okay that's
awesome that's awesome from the YouTube
ra coming over to the Facebook also just
you know shout-out to you guys for who
are watching this for first time they
didn't know and that's good feedback and
I'll learn to incorporate that okay so
there's been another another amount of
of comments on the on the Facebook okay
alright there is if it's an object I
don't think so okay so they're still on
Facebook they were talking about the the
ship of thesis this yes I'm answer to
that lies in buckminster fuller model
here let me switch it over to you for
you guys
lies in books book monsters folders
model of multidimensionality same object
different every energy length totally
agree on the short term rewards leading
to non happiness giggle that you saw
that and you're glad you enjoyed that
and then because gas is naturally
created an atmosphere and the gases
create such no interesting I agree
knowing thyself boundaries of self and
standing up for our boundaries are key I
as someone who worked on decentralized
networks don't agree with systems being
our salvation
I believe overcoming our own social
fears and getting back into grassroots
without real connection life isn't from
my perspective yeah that's really well
said there let me let me jump into that
because I was at that does a good point
there Blake so the idea is that it's not
necessarily that decentralized systems
are all of a sudden gonna cure the
cancers from society the parasites of
society are the fact that we don't
understand ourselves that we have to
really deeply tune into our own self
work first and foremost and then it
doesn't matter if there's whatever
systems really exist past that besides
of the systems to get us water and food
and shelter and the basic needs we
because once you understand yourself you
live with a certain level of Zen and
contentless but at the same time you
still need food and water and shelter so
it's it's extremely complicated nuanced
but I'm glad you brought that up Kai
Faust on Facebook asks have you been
able to monetize a simulation alright
let's go over there for you
all right have you been able to monetize
simulation yet mmm-hmm good question
so let's tell you guys where we're at so
we are currently have a couple forms of
monetization and there are pretty much I
guess three forms of monetization let's
be as transparent as possible because
it's weird when people are being not
transparent in a world where
everything's posted on the Internet but
for some reason things are still not
transparent in organizations like who's
who where's money coming from for
certain people so let's get as
absolutely transparent as possible so we
have three different sources of
financing for simulation the first one
is our patreon account so every single
dollar that's given to us on patreon
goes into increasing our impact of what
we do here that means doing things like
being able to make better content
everything from being able to pay
someone that comes in Paulette to come
in and we aim to pay him at least 300
bucks for a day's worth of work and what
Paul does is he helps us put together a
very powerful 30 or 60 second video that
talks about things like civilization
design in the hundred billion people
that lived and died before us to build
this world and so we make really
interesting content like that so anyway
doing things like paying him or even
just buying food so that we can just
live and we do our best to stay as
frugal as possible with what we purchase
and how we survive and paying for our
rent here our rent here is about two
thousand bucks a month in San Francisco
and then on top of that we have business
class internet for the streaming
purposes we have equipment expenses that
we just got you know we just need and we
got a new computer chair but but we
still you know because we were literally
sitting on a folding chair behind our
editing station and it
super uncomfortable things like this
equipment that you see ahead of us we're
using an old box light right now that is
not eco-friendly at all we need to get
an LED light ring those are like a
hundred bucks you know huge shout out to
anyone that can literally just you know
pay pal simulation series at gmail.com a
hundred bucks or go on patreon and do it
because we could get that LED light ring
we need max tegmark a famous AI
scientist in Boston wants to interview
us or wants us to interview him and we
can't afford to go fly there to
interview him for our show you know this
happens all the time that we get these
powerful requests from people around the
world and we just can't go there and
interview them so so we're just stuck
waiting for them to come to us anyway so
patreon support then ticket sale so we
sell tickets at live events so that
means everything from a you know a
50-seat event with 5-0 people like not
as many people all the way up to a 500
seat event so we sell tickets at any
range of those events but you know you
have to you know we pay speakers
anywhere from you know just a couple
hundred bucks or small events all the
way up to ten thousand or more dollars
for the big events and then there's all
these other production costs the venue
rental cost the security cost the
marketing cost the video production
costs you want to pay people because you
want it show people that you love them
and you give them respect and care for
absolutely everything that they helped
contribute to if you want to actually
give them lots of pay because you care
about them and you care about their
health and their well-being so even if
you break even on an event it's a good
that you pay other people money so that
they can live healthy and they can see
that you have appreciated them so we do
that we have a very high bar of
threshold with how well we treat people
and then so ticket sales patreon and
then lastly occasionally we'll take some
of the equipment that we have here and
we'll take it over to a conference that
we really like and we'll help produce
that conference for them and then we'll
sometimes it's a good partnership for us
and we don't charge sometimes we do
charge because we obviously have to pay
people that go and do camera operations
and stuff like that so those are like
the three main methods for monetization
there's a lot of other things to explore
like YouTube partnership we're
approaching ten thousand subs on YouTube
but YouTube's been a little bit
difficult to work with on the
monetization side of things like
literally we have like five hundred and
thirty videos or something on our
channel and only like five of them have
ever had any issue and it's because we
like embedded another video within our
video and which so many people do anyway
over 99% of our content is original
content but yet YouTube has declined our
monetization for the last like nine
months and we've just kept applying and
applying and they've declined our
monetization because we don't because we
infringe on the original content thing
it's ridiculous so anyway that's been um
that's been a nightmare and you know
that YouTube you know that Google and
Facebook don't have phone numbers for
you to call which is ridiculous that
they don't have phone numbers so they're
the most powerful wealthy organizations
and they don't have phone numbers for
people to call for support especially
for their content creators anyway and we
have a lot of other ways to monetize as
well that we have to explore like we
would love for people to to do
production collaborations with us anyway
I could go on on that for way too long
so that's how we monetize let's see I
think we're pretty good on on this QA
alright the reason why I've subscribed
to you and found this discussion is
because someone I follow and respect
follows you Oh interesting so that's you
know that's coming from YouTube from our
our Lee here oh I can't actually zoomed
up that far for some reason
oh no it's that's weird
oh they're real now it's letting me show
you oh man let's see okay let me
interesting right now I'm having trouble
in the chat too interesting okay
oh there it is finally okay I'm there
again the reason why I've subscribed to
you and found this discussion is because
someone I follow and respect follows you
interesting are early thank you for
saying that and thanks to your friend
but um that you fall in respect that
they follow us that's really nice of
them and that I'm happy that you found
it and I'm happy that you guys mentioned
to me that you would like to know who I
am
and you know who we are here and what we
do I can make that a little bit more I
can definitely make that more clear and
I appreciate that that's it's a good
point good point
alright wrapping up wrapping up wrapping
up Nikolas Peterson joined shout out to
you on Facebook thanks for joining
all right wrapping up thank you everyone
for tuning in to am a number two this
has been ridiculously fun I greatly
appreciate you all this was a lot of fun
I've learned a lot from this AMA but you
guys are very very interesting and
intelligent and ask really good
questions Kai Foss Thank You Alan keep
it up you guys are working so hard I
know you're all going to be rewarded
generously much appreciated Kai thank
you very much and I think a lot of what
I think one moment I think a lot of what
happens with people that are rewarded
generously is that they take on a lot of
risk in their life so the more that you
take on risk of self actualizing and I
mean literally sacrificing almost
everything in your life sacrificing
passing time with your families
sacrificing passing time with your
spouse
sacrificing time doing doing beer
gardens or doing netflix and chill' or
you you know there's so many ways to get
to get distracted by the Netflix is in
the in the happy hours that take you
away from creative endeavoring I'm not
saying you should you have to take time
away from your you know your family and
your and your and your partners and
stuff but you actually do also have to
have to take time away from that
otherwise you'll get stuck in just
constantly passing time with them maybe
that's your goal is that you want to
only pass time with your partners and
your and your and your and your parents
more but in order for you to actually
disproportionately earn rewards in
today's value system people want you to
provide them with value and the way to
provide people with value is to hustle
your ass off like Gary Vaynerchuk says
he says eat [ __ ] eat [ __ ] eat [ __ ] for
10 years
eat [ __ ] from when you're 20 until
you're 30 I mean eat [ __ ] every day live
poor as [ __ ] constantly for 10 years
wake up and grind and hustle all day
long applying the Pareto principle find
the greatest signal in all of the noise
and apply that into your life in
maximizing your value that you can
provide to other people in maximizing
your potential in the world and all of a
sudden you'll see a disproportionate
amount of rewards coming your way after
ten years you have to be patient you
have to be patient and that will happen
so and if you bring people value of of
communion with the infinite and actually
just prospering together collectively I
was a civilization that if you bring
that forth people will join you in the
movement you know people can sniff out
those that are in it for just money and
greed and corruption and fame and and
stuff that when you're in it for just
those things people can sniff that out
fast
Nicholas Peterson that point amen
brother that hit at home thanks Brad
thanks my man I really appreciate you
Brad's also a friend from back home in
Sioux Falls that I grew up with as well
I appreciate that my man
Nicholas Peterson kicking butt and
taking names brother I love seeing you
thrive also I left the kitchen life paid
minimum no benefits now I'm doing
personal training with benefits I love
it wow that's dope
that heats up that needs a highlight
that needs a highlight I love seeing
this that is so freakin cool oh man if
we can get more people to you know to
take these leaps of faith like you have
to start somewhere with working
somewhere that you don't necessarily
find fulfilling but you have to gameplan
finding somewhere filling as your next
lily pad that you're jumping to the next
lily pad you when you jump to the next
one if the game plan where it is and how
to get there strategically then you can
jump from the lily pad to the other one
and land somewhere like Nick did where
now he's doing personal training with
benefits he's doing something that he
likes more with benefits
so it's this it's this idea that you got
to strategically plan your next step
what you want to do with your life and
that's a process called future authoring
future authoring is so damn important
it's like you know yourself and then you
know where you want to go and you map
out how to get there and you go there I
think we still have a discount code for
for Jordan Peterson's um self authoring
program which is really good and I
highly recommend it it's discount code
simulation in itself authoring dot-com
and go take a look at it
alright that is that is all folks that's
it we got a couple more comments
gratitude and love from Josh Marin thank
you from our early on YouTube and then I
get it now after watching his
Ted appreciate the fact he doesn't leave
for anything specific so what is time
interesting melody he couldn't that's
night that's nice of you that that you
say that you say that a melody down here
said that melody got a little bit more
about what I guess I represent but that
I don't lead for anything specific and
that's actually that's an extremely
important part of who I am is that I'm
so multidisciplinary my mental lattice
is so Polymathic that I don't lead for
specific things i what i do is i if you
want to label a specific lead it's like
how do we prosper maximally as a
civilization that's what I lead for
that's what I aim to inspire other
people to care about prospering
maximally as a civilization we can
[ __ ] do it we can get there together
I'm so believing it and that's that's my
mission that's my mission in this life
on this earth orbiting the star is to
help civilization figure out how to
maximally prosper together that's my
mission in this life on this rock in the
next level will be something different
melody please I love it I love it all
right that's it that's it that's it much
love everyone thank you so much for
tuning in I tremendously appreciate your
love and support so much thank you thank
you thank you love you I love you I love
you love you and love you because
without love we can't get there but we
also can't get there without strategic
execution on moving the ball forward on
the frameworks and resource flows that
are going to break apart the structure
of violence is and enable that
civilizational maximum prosperity
together okay you know the way to follow
us if you don't yet check out all the
links below you can follow simulation
all those links below also you know put
together your next question list for
next time go and come and go you know
when you watch this give us your
thoughts in the comments these questions
that we've been that we've been
answering and we'd love to hear from you
also we have a telegram we have a
Grahame like a group chat for simulation
with the stop provoking questions the
link is in in the bio of the YouTube as
well and yeah follow us across those
platforms go watch the TEDx talk that I
gave on the art of powerful questions
and attention economics and shattering
through those surface level
conversations that's also links in the
bio of this video again I'm Alan Saki
and I'm the host of simulation and I
love you all thank you very much for
tuning in build the future manifest your
destiny into the world everyone
much love and let's exit out with the
morning stroll soundtrack I like this
[Music]